I I met Nicholas Cage at a c um Camp no
not Camp what's not caners uh anyway he
was in there eating while we were
filming there one day yeah he was eating
alone fascinating the placeat was packed
to the gills and he got up to leave and
I said I'm going to Saun her out at the
same time he's leaving just maybe maybe
we oh sorry hey oh oh my God are you
aren't you yeah yeah and and then he was
standing outside and he's like and then
my buddy goes up to him and he goes oh
Mr Mr cage can I help you with anything
we had on the tie cuz we were working
something and he goes I need a c cab and
then my friend hails a cab and he goes
to give my friend a 20 I think he
probably didn't take it and then my
friend put him in the cab Clos it
instead have great drove away but I did
take a picture with him do you have it
will you send it to me I do have it if
you just Google me and him we won't make
people do the extra work we're going to
put it up right here okay most of the
time when I take a picture with I'm like
oh my God I'm getting a picture with
this it always is bad it's always bad I
look bad my f something I like the
picture I took with him that's what I
always remember W yeah wow I get what
you're saying